the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video
well my friends we finally have another
official update from hbo
i must say this information is very
interesting because it could drastically
change the way some of the events unfold
in-house of the dragon
now as you all know hbo has been
developing a new game of thrones series
based on george rr martin's fire and
blood
house of the dragon will focus on the
fall of house targaryen
this was when they fought their own
flesh and blood over the iron throne
during a series of events known as the
dance of dragons
hbo actually started developing this
show before game of thrones ended but
now we're less than a year away from
house of the dragon finally airing on
hbo max
it won't be long before all of us are
back in westeros again
and i for one cannot wait now if you're
someone who stays up to date on all of
this information then you would know
they have already started filming some
of their episodes for the first season
hbo has even already revealed official
photos of some of the main characters
while they were on set
in these photos are rhaenyra targaryen
and her uncle daemon who is also her
lover i might add
in another one of these photos is serato
hightower and his daughter allison
hightower
who goes on to become the queen after
she marries rhaenyra's father king
viserys
now after viserys dies house of the
dragon will mostly focus on rhinera and
alison's fight over the iron throne you
see before viserys died
he named his daughter rhaenyra as his
heir he made sure
she was next in line for the iron throne
however as soon as he died
his wife alicent along with the help of
others
set their son aegon on the iron throne
instead that led to an all-out war
amongst house targaryen
rhaenyra believes the iron throne should
be her since her father made her the
heir
and allison believes her son aegon
should have the iron throne since he is
the firstborn son of king viserys
rhaenara and alison will end up
sacrificing just about everything they
love
as this family nearly wipes itself off
the map during the dance of dragons
now if you go back to these photos you
can see hbo has brought in actress emma
darcy who will be our rhinera targaryen
and they also brought in actress olivia
cook who will be our alice in hightower
based on the ages of these actresses it
gave us a good idea of when this series
will begin
since they're near the age of 30 it
seemed as if house of the dragon would
begin right around the death of king
viserys
that would actually make a lot of sense
since it's what leads us right
into the dance of dragons when all of
the fighting begins that's what i have
been assuming would happen
but that was until hbo just made their
most recent announcement
they've officially hired new actresses
who will portray the younger versions of
rhaenyra targaryen and allison hightower
according to house of the dragon's
verified account hbo has brought in
emily carey who will be the younger
alison hightower
hbo also brought in millie alcock who
will be the younger version of rhaenyra
targaryen
this is very interesting because it
could change everything
now maybe they will only use them for
flashback scenes
but if that's the case it makes me
wonder who all will be involved in those
scenes
as of right now these are the only
characters that we know of that will
have a younger
and older version of themselves so if
they do have some flashback scenes they
might only focus on these characters
since they haven't made
any other announcements about other
characters getting younger actors as
well
this also lets me know that rhaenara and
alicent will definitely be the main
focus of the show
but that seemed obvious already now
another thing that house of the dragon
could do is have an entire first episode
set several years before the main events
the new actresses
look a lot younger than emma and olivia
so my guess is whenever we see them on
screen
it could be roughly a decade before the
main story
that's another reason why i think they
might be here for flashback scenes only
one thing that is very interesting
though is the fact that they felt the
need to officially announce this
i don't remember hbo ever doing that
when game of thrones hired actors who
were only in flashback scenes
since the announcement was so official
it makes me think the actresses will
have a significant role as well
i just hope we aren't bouncing back and
forth between two different timelines
throughout the whole season
i would hate it if they kept bouncing
back in time with every episode
if it were up to me i would only do a
few flashback scenes with them or at the
most i would have the first
episode set several years before the
main story
then at the beginning of the second
episode you could just say 10 years
later or whatever
now it is hard to say how big of a gap
this will be since hbo
always changes the ages of characters
they could make the age gap seem a lot
smaller
or bigger depending on what they need if
you remember ned stark was around 35
years old in the books
but the actor sean bean was obviously a
lot older than that
all i really know is emily carey and
millie alcock are about 10 years younger
than emma and olivia
but that doesn't mean their age
difference will be the same in the show
one thing we could see is the wedding of
alison and king viserys since the
actress is the same age alicent was once
she got married in the story
this is all just speculation of course
because it's really hard to say how this
first season will unfold
now that they've brought in these
younger actors it could have a
significant impact to the way the story
is adapted onto the screen
i know i am very interested in seeing
how things continue to evolve as more
information is released
hopefully there are more updates in the
near future as of right now
filming on house of the dragon has been
kept on the down low over the last few
weeks
my guess is they have been filming a lot
of scenes indoors but hopefully that
changes as well
i would love to see some more photos of
the actors on set
only then will we get a better sense of
what will happen in this first season
let me know what your thoughts are on
all of this down below
how do you think the first season will
unfold how do you think they will
utilize the younger actors
as always i will let you know if any
more details are released
make sure you subscribe if you want to
stay up to date on any and all
information regarding house of the
dragon
i want to thank all of you for watching
my videos once again
i hope everyone has a great day i will
see you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you